a lot of walk up to another episode of
what's in the box
I'm Cisco I'm Ebert man and this is the
show where we dive into well done into
the box open it up look at what's inside
we can't do any of that till homeboy
here Arthur pulls the sword out the
stone sticks back into the stone cuts
across the stone open the stone and pull
out the juicy guts we're good I think
[Music]
look at this [ __ ] right here son ma'am
in the minimun a ma'am and a minute of
the race stands toast
cluster venom at a minimum a minimum he
got he got Louis Tolly
manaman a minimum in a minute do you
know that's not the Ghostbusters song at
all definitely done by the same people
who like to have all the different hands
what do you think this hands well cuz
they have eight hands
this is nuts who's doing these is it
diamond it is diamond select oh my god
these are fantastic alright man we got
ourselves some Ghostbusters figures look
at the [ __ ] amazing detail on this
there's no day no Lisl I talked to Dana
for everyone who's been waiting for the
right Sigourney Weaver figured this is
it man look how good that looks and if
you've been waiting for a Rick Moranis
figure since the todd mcfarlane memory
did the Bob and Doug McKenzie figures
yes that's the only other time you had a
Rick Moranis figure now you got one
looks this good look at that dude that's
crazy that's like circa
sctv Rick Moranis six more figures are
coming but these just came out all right
who's missing maybe Slimer Slimer at the
marshmallow man would that be a figure
wouldn't that be something secretary
ghostbusters what do you want you know
what I think here's gonna be the cool
dragon dog yeah
okay who brought the dog I love this
movie so much dude I saw in a theater
with my friend Mike bellicose and my
parents it was a movie you can watch
with your parents and then still have a
good time and I remember afterwards even
mourn for me I went to Bennigan's it was
called and it was the day the day that
they introduced mozzarella sticks to the
menu we might have been the first family
to taste mozzarella stick yes I think I
don't know I've always told myself that
makes me feel more important two amazing
things happen that day Ghostbusters and
mozzarella sticks forever Tosh just
goodness I'm so in love with these
Ghostbusters figures I ain't even gonna
[ __ ] about the fact that it's gonna
take you 20 minutes to pull this figure
out of the packaging look at this look
at all the stuff they got look at that
sir I think we hold it like this
they need two hands brother [ __ ] as
powerful
shootin kicks
oh they have this thing member I was
telling you a ghost trap Shh yeah and
then you step on this climber gets
caught in we came we saw we kicked its
ass I'm imagining that Slimer is one of
the figures look at this man has a
little bit but he Gong Yoos I can't
compete for streams to go on their guns
though do you know how to do that this
little thing goes right sure who's your
favorite character did you have a
favorite Bill Murray that's right boys
it's dr. Venkman I think every character
that I write in all the movies like
Randall and Brody they're all
descendants of Peter Venkman or John
winger who Bill Murray played in
pinstripes so am I to understand that
you meant completed your training on
your own when we were kids he was like
our human Bugs Bunny
Bill Murray like he could do and get
away with and say the things that Bugs
Bunny could get away with Bill Murray
either made our generation better or
completely ruined us by being a role
model that we all wanted to be so bad
laughs this is one of the only actors on
the planet that I love Warren maybe like
you but I don't think I'd ever work with
them it's difficult to get ahold of them
and he got a call a number and you hey
man we want you to be in our movie
and if he shows up he's into it shows up
for Wes Anderson you know he wouldn't
show up for my fat ass but I've always
loved [ __ ] him what about you is your
favorite ghost you know this one's here
I've Blues Brothers of course dan
Aykroyd man one half of the Blues
Brothers come over here in front of me
in fact Ghostbusters was supposed to be
dan Aykroyd and John Belushi he wrote it
for him and Belushi Belushi died then
they waited a few years and they wound
up doing it okay don't worry
winston zeddemore man he's he's been on
comic book men he was also in hand that
rocks the cradle' he's a phenomenal
[ __ ] actor do you believe in UFOs
astral projections mental telepathy ESP
clairvoyance spirit photography
telekinetic movement full trance mediums
the Loch Ness monster and the theory of
Atlantis if there's a steady paycheck in
it I'll believe anything you say
Egon who is played by the great Harold
Ramis Harold Ramos was a director
himself so he directed one of my
favorite movies of all time national
lampoon's vacation you can hear his
voice in at one point as well but he was
also an actor he came from SC TV so he
worked with like John Candy and Rick
Moranis and Dave Thomas and then he
wound up being in this flick with these
guys man and he went on to like he
directed Groundhog Day whose amazing
amazing director they're making an
all-girl Ghostbusters but yeah so none
of this sausage party anymore man all
ladies I'm all for it some people when
they announced it were like [ __ ]
ghostbusters should be boys I don't give
a [ __ ] man just give me another [ __ ]
ghostbusters you know I'm awaiting for
another one like I remember seeing
ghostbusters ghostbusters 2 and then for
the last 25 30 years Ghostbuster
droughts man so now we're gonna get
another flick and from what I understand
they're gonna build out their universe
they've realized they got like gold man
ghosts but nobody else got Ghostbusters
so the like let's do it to death Thor
Chris Hemsworth is playing there like
annie potts the one who's like weak
[Music]
and when I saw that movie I was like why
don't we have a fireman's pole in our
house wow this place is great we lived
on one floor but still I was like we
need this do you like this movie I do I
do I'm not I mean you know I'm not die
hard I might buy the ambulance
MAME I said what it's actually good by
the ambi right no one oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
I did like to move but I'm just saying I
know people are like diehard like you go
to Kampala mentions and there's at least
eight people dress up as Ghostbusters me
and Mike Bell coasted Ghostbusters in
eighth grade when we were 13 for
Halloween we built proton packs myths
the outfits we made ourselves and all
that it was pretty cool and then his
brother took the outfits and him and his
friend warm up to like Henry Hudson
regional the high school and they won an
award with our outfits I was always very
proud of that
Bill Murray says dick in it there's true
this man has no dick everything was mine
with our system until the power grid was
shut off by [ __ ] here they caused an
explosion is this true yes it's true
this man has no dick and I've got a
ghost [ __ ] scene that was weird
watching that with my parents here in
the movie theater one point down a core
he's having a dream to ghost like you
see his pants zip open and [ __ ] and like
I looked over at my parents my parents
kind of looked over at me both of us
going like do they know what that is and
then you looked away and you look back
and [ __ ] and your mom was like I guess
they know what that is okay man we got
one more big box here so do what you
gotta cut it cross the streams
all right oh nice
oh [ __ ] it's the Stay Puft Marshmallow
Man
well there's something you don't see
every day
oh my god look this is so beautiful
oh it's a bank there's a hole in the
back I hope it's a bank
it's a real good looking it's good good
firm Bank it is a 24 inch Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man back
that's fantastic dude when I was a kid
like this is the [ __ ] I wanted man like
mom dad could you get me a gigantic
ghostbusters Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
Bank and they would have said no cuz we
were poor but still it would have been
nice to ask for it but we couldn't even
know to ask for because they didn't make
[ __ ] this cool man this is phenomenal
and we got some fun fun what is this
marshmallow mini bow really happens on
the show I think this kimba is combined
here they had to shoot you in their
bunghole with marshmallows don't weigh
in for the bunghole aim right for the
mouth marshmallow straight shooter
oh it's like a blowgun dude Oh blows
mini marshmallows 30 feet away
I wish I can get some money from 20 feet
away what we got here is a marshmallow
peashooter lookin thing as marshmallow
bone arrow for the ass you take your
marshmallows your miniature marshmallows
you stick them into the chamber there's
one in the tumor okay here we go so you
have that much right blow at the camera
see this works ready
how do you put your whole mouth over it
or just like that like that good times
kids let's test this one I'm going for
that camera baby oh not very I think
this one might have more deadly accuracy
all right does I like the axe know what
I'm saying could you imagine you're just
like racing through the jungle and shot
in the neck with a marshmallow
all right so I'm going for the middle
camera ready aiming high but I keep
hitting nuts
[Music]
you're [ __ ] Miles Davis oh and I was
like I gotta figure it out - I'm telling
you if I was ever being at least Oh
mine's very like this is not the weapon
have if you're being chased go for all
right load her up chase me ready and go
yes son of a [ __ ] only I could load
this Oh
all right here's how to shoot one into
my mouth with the arrow okay ready
hold on should I put on safety glasses
[Music]
try again you go for your mouth like
this open up oh did you taste it oh [ __ ]
yes very well who doubts close this is
kind of homoerotic and I'm like you open
your mouth you also let a little liquid
fly with that one this kids is how you
waste a good bag on marshmallows
nature's food oh great cause ow
how do you [ __ ] prick that's my eye
[Music]
gooks
oh so close
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chicken dinner
that is the right diet the Ghostbusters
blowgun marshmallow die cuz you'll never
eat let's see oh my lord man
look at all this wonderful gorgeous
nonsense just crossing the streams right
in front of us like you got the bank you
got the figures you got you know what
I'm saying
this is positivity kids this is good
times just like the Real Ghostbusters
that's what came out of the box this
week you are seize pull other things out
of the box we'll do it man just let us
know right to the screen junkies a
Twitter or Facebook
hello alright at this address below us
man and let us know what you want to see
us open up man I don't know if we'll
open up anything as fun as these have
been this is this is aren't you jealous
this is our job
this is our job we're gonna go blow each
other with these for the next two hours
Ms Hollywood anyway there it is folks
what's in the box for this week is at an
end I'm Kevin Smith JC Museum what's in
the box this week has been we're gonna
call this
[Music]
you